semur-en-auxois accueille chaque année
plus de 35 mille touristes c'est l'une
des villes les plus visitées de
côte-d'or et pour découvrir la cité
médiévale on a le choix
on peut flâner dans les rues on peut
aussi profiter d'une visite guidée pour
replonger dans l'ambiance du moyen-âge
déjà pour comprendre l'histoire de la
ville et on comprend que notre ville ait
bâti son rocher de granit rose
et puis au petit sorcier vous avez la
rivière qui est la revend son qui a crû
dans la partie la plus tendre des
rochers pour l'encercler dans son
meilleur qui fait clairement que nous
avons une ville hôte est une ville basse
il ya une légende et pas des moindres
qui dit que c'est hercules en personne
qui à son retour d'espagne auraient
creusé le bras de la rivière et ainsi
former le caractère fortifiée de notre
bible il y à la légende et il ya
l'histoire d'une ancienne citadelle
célèbre pour ses remparts ses portes
fortifiées et sa devise
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire plus fort on
la voit tancer estrangers bien est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire bienvenue
et que le saumurois suppléant la
compagnie de personnes venues d'ailleurs
des visiteurs qui auront droit à un
comité d'accueil plutôt inattendue une
troupe de joyeux manon qui a pris
l'habitude chaque été de s'inviter dans
les visites guidées
on a décidé de vanille mais après c'est
visible parce que c'est vrai que ce
genre de visite à dans une ville il ya
des fois il ya des enfants et tout et
c'est un peu long pour les enfants et on
a dit on va faire des pics scène tout au
long du trajet pour animer pour là pour
faire plaisir à pierre
je pense que vous jouer les
perturbateurs a le même bien faire
quelques facéties
à part ça
à
alors nous allons traiter l'eau pour
notre dame donc le bourg commerçants
vous rejoint justement la ville fasse le
smur des faubourgs celui des artisans
s'il est que veulent bien céder le
passage une fois sorti sans encombre de
l'enceinte fortifiée
les visiteurs vont pouvoir prendre la
mesure de l'ancienne citadelle
imaginez 16 à 18 tours qui habillait le
rocher de granit d'accord et qui faisait
de ce mur neuf il dit
imprenable les ducs de bourgogne avait
vraiment ce côté très ostentatoire 1 à 2
sur fortifier la ville en contrebas au
bord de l'armançon dans un quartier qui
abritait des tanneries et des draperies
au moyen-âge semur-en-auxois conserve
une autre de ses curiosités bien plus
récentes
l'un des tout derniers bateaux lavoirs
de bourgogne on a plutôt l'habitude
d'arpenter saviez haute c'est vraiment
ce que l'on voit en premier abord et
cette ville base c'est vrai qu'elle
n'est pas très connue finalement c'est
pour ça qu'on a envie de vous la montrer
de vous la faire découvrir de vous la
faire aimer et aussi de découvrir des
petites choses comme ça qu'on ne
connaîtrait pas si on ne faisait pas des
visites ou si on n'allait pas un petit
peu en dehors des sentiers battus
les gueux en éclaireur à la nuit tombée
il est temps de regagner la ville hôte
l'ancien donjon où venaient se réfugier
des villageois en cas de siège cent
quarante et une marche à gravir la nasa
suit 16 parties fin ces visites
nocturnes sont organisées tous les
vendredis du mois de juillet mais on
peut bien sûr aussi découvrir
semur-en-auxois le jour c'est le mardi
après midi
l'occasion de découvrir le patrimoine
architectural de la cité médiévale peut
être plus en détail mais en se privant
d'un final haut en couleurs